going to break into the business news
now and hop over to brussels where the
vice president of the european
commission maro sefkovic is speaking
following news at the eu's taking legal
action against the uk for its plan to
override parts of the brexit deal on
northern ireland let's just listen in
good morning
on
monday the uk government tabled
legislation confirming
its intention to unilaterally break
international law
more precisely to break an agreement
that protects peace and stability in
northern ireland
an agreement that we reached together
only two years ago
let there be
no doubt
there is no legal
nor political justification whatsoever
for unilaterally changing an
international agreement
opening the door to unilaterally
changing an international agreement is a
breach of international law as well
so let's called a spate expect this is
illegal
the uk bill is extremely damaging to
mutual trust
and respect between the eu and the uk
it has created deep uncertainty and
casts a shadow over our overall
cooperation
all at the time and respect for
international agreements has never been
more important
that is why the commission has today
decided to take legal action
against the united kingdom for not
complying with significant parts of the
protocol on ireland northern ireland
we have been withholding this legal
action over the last year
because we wanted to create a
constructive atmosphere to find
solutions
the uk government's decision has left us
with no choice but to act
first we are proceeding a step further
with the infringement process we
launched in march 2021
regarding for instance the movement of
agri-food
if the uk doesn't reply within two
months we may take them to the court of
justice
second
we are launching two new infringements
against the uk
one for failing to carry out the
necessary controls at the border control
posts in northern ireland by ensuring
adequate staffing and infrastructure
and one
for failing to provide the eu with
essential trade statistics data to
enable the eu to protect its single
market
ladies and gentlemen
the protocol
was the solution agreed with the uk
government to protect the good friday
belfast agreement in all its dimensions
avoid a hard border on the island of
ireland
and protect the integrity of the eu's
single market
we know that there are some practical
difficulties in implementing it
we have said so openly
that is why my team and i
had been engaging extensively with all
stakeholders
on the ground resulting in a set of
solutions put forward in october showing
genuine and unprecedented flexibility
for example our proposals would reduce
sanitary and phytosanitary checks and
controls by by more than 80 percent
they would cut customs paperwork in half
create an express lane for goods moving
from great britain to northern ireland
simplify certification
a single three-page document for whole
glory full of different goods
and they would
allow even the movement
of certain goods that would otherwise be
restricted such as chilled meat like
sausages
this is a solid offer
making a tangible difference on the
ground
today we have fleshed out these
proposals proving
they can work and they can work fast
we have even published the draft
certificates that businesses would need
to fill out showing just how simple and
easy they are to fill in
and i would like to show it to you
these are the three pages which needs to
be filled
perilously or one
once per month not 300 not 33
this how simple it is and this what we
can do if we work well together
because our proposals are all about
simplification
and therefore in stark contrast with for
instance a dual regulatory regime
proposed by the uk
a dual set of rules eu and uk
would lead to a mounting of paperwork
and bureaucracy
enough to bury a small business in
northern ireland that wants to profit
from access to both
the uk's internal and eu's single market
at once
so once again
permanent solutions and simple
operations of the protocol proposed by
the eu versus
constant uncertainty with uk ministers
having an open hand to change the rules
on a whim
we want northern ireland to embrace the
all benefits of this unique position
because our commitment to the people of
northern ireland is unshakable
despite today's legal action our door
remains open to dialogue
we want to discuss these solutions with
the uk government
given that the uk hasn't sat down at the
table with us since
february i think it's a high time to
show some political will to find joint
solutions
the uk has stated that for us to talk
the eu must be willing to change the
protocol
on the contrary we have always said that
our package of proposals has never been
a take it or leave it offer
it can evolve but it is not an
unconditional offer there must be
safeguards included
that protect the single market
because the risks for our market are
real
not theoretical
and the conditions which allow northern
ireland to access the eu single market
for goods are not for the uk to change
it's simply legally and politically
inconceivable
that the uk government decides
unilaterally what kind of goods can
enter our single market
this is not the path for the two
partners
standing shoulder to shoulder when
facing global challenge
challenges and that uh
this uh should be uh
forged like that
i'm convinced that with political will
we can find solutions for people and
businesses
in northern ireland but this must be
done jointly thank you
thank you very much vice president we'll
now take a few questions just to let you
know first of all we have published
press material online as well as the two
position papers which the vice president
referred to including the documents that
he showed so you'll find all of that
online adam please first
uh adam parsons from sky news uh mr
cervkovich
there are lots of people here in
brussels who think that the european
commission is being played by the
british government for its own domestic
concerns
do you have trust in the good faith of
boris johnson and liz truss
and if not were you tempted to go harder
and further with the legal proceedings
that you've taken against the british
government or do you still have those
options up your sleeve
thank you very much for that question of
course
i think our today's action the fact that
we have to start the legal proceedings
and legal action against
our ally against
our partner
in this very difficult times where we
face uh together the global challenges
is pretty telling what the level of the
trust
uh we have
uh at the same time we
are fully
aware of the current circumstances
in the world in europe and in northern
ireland and therefore for us
the peace on the island
and our commitment to the people of
northern ireland
uh have i would say overriding
uh principle in
how we
approach these negotiations therefore
we decided that our
response should be measured
should be proportionate
and
we are offering not only legal action
here today but we've been fleshing out
what concretely we could do
i was showing showing you three pages of
the of the certificate three pages
and i can also tell you that
what we are fleshing out in our today's
proposals exactly responds uh to the
queries to the questions to the
propositions i heard when i personally
visited northern ireland and what i
heard since then because i i'm in
regular contact with the business
community with civic society and to the
political leaders
in
northern ireland what they what they
want us to focus on is is to straight
reduce administrative burden make the
operation of the protocol as smooth as
possible and this is exactly what we are
what we are doing
and what we are offering is joint
solution which would offer stability we
should offer legal certainty we should
offer legal clarity
and
when you are talking to the to the
business operators and
potential investors what you hear from
them
you know
for us it's very important to know
if we are going to invest are we going
to produce for 5 million
50 million or 500 million
and that has i would say
very important implications we
offered and promised
the people of northern ireland to have
the best of the both worlds
and this is what we want to offer them
what we are now getting
in form of this draft bill would be the
mounting
uh monstrous mounting of paperwork
which
uh the business operators in the
northern northern ireland will have will
have to fill up i mean go and ask
i don't know the milk producers in in
northern ireland
how how he or she can produce the milk
one sort for eu another one for the uk
or any kind of manufacturer
who wants to benefit from the access
to both markets of the uk and the eu
should have two different production
lines so so therefore what i'm what i'm
saying here is let's focus on
practicalities let's focus on how to
make the operation of the protocol
smooth and this is what what we are
going to do therefore our uh response
today uh is measured uh therefore it's
proportionate and uh that's the that's
the reason why we also are fleshing out
that what we are putting on the table
it's really often ready
if we have a
positive reaction from the uk side
political will and engagement this can
be done in no time as we did it with the
medicines
we demonstrated we can sort out a very
difficult issue with a very short period
of time and what we are offering here
are ready-made recipes how we can solve
the problems of sps checks problems of
customs procedures and as i said
we always been ready to discuss other
issues as well but there was radio
silence from the uk side since february